نعم ، سأقوم ببعض التدريبات التي أعمل بها مع
الكلاب لتدريبهم على استخدام ماسح التصوير بالرنين
المغناطيسي ومحاولة اكتشاف ما الذي
يجعلهم يقرؤون وماذا يفكرون ،
اسمي جريجوري بيرنز
، أنا عالم أعصاب في جامعة إيموري
في أتلانتا  جورجيا لقد نشأت مع
الكلاب وعشت مع الكلاب إلى حد
كبير طوال حياتي ، فقد توفي أحد كلابي المفضلة
في مؤخرة
ذهني وبدأت أتساءل هل أحبني هذا الكلب
بالطريقة التي أحببته بها و
كانت هذه حقًا بداية
كل هذه الأشياء الأساسية التي بدأنا
في تصنيفها في البشر على الأقل في
العلامات التجارية البشرية التي نريد القيام بها في الكلاب إذا كان من
الممكن تدريب الكلاب على الدخول في آلة التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي ومن
ثم ربما يمكننا اكتشاف
اكتشفوا ما يفكرون فيه بالفعل ، لذا لدينا
كلبة في ماسح ضوئي هي كاتي
وهي من المخضرمين في المشروع ، ربما يكون هذا في
حوالي 15 مرة
قامت فيها بهذا
[موسيقى]
فقط لديها فكرة حسنًا ، فلنقم
بتدريب الكلاب  ماسح ضوئي لم
يتضح على الفور كيف سيذهب
حول دوي  إن ماسحات التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي و ng
ليست أكثر البيئات متعة.
Callie هو الكلب الأسود الصغير الذي
كان أول كلب يتدرب على مشروع الكلب
الذي قمت ببناء جهاز محاكاة للتصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي ، لذلك
هذا هو المحاكي الذي بنيته هنا
في الطابق السفلي الخاص بي ثم نحن  بدأنا في إضافة
تسجيلات لملاحظات الماسح الضوئي والتي هي في
الواقع بصوت عالٍ جدًا ، لقد بدأنا للتو في
العمل معك تعرف المعالجات
والتعزيز الإيجابي لمعرفة ما إذا كان
بإمكاننا حملها على الدخول في هذا الشيء الذي
ثبت أنه سهل جدًا ،
ثم ما فعلناه كان  نحن نوعًا ما
نضع كلمة شفهية ، هل تريد الانضمام إلى هذا
المشروع الذي تريد تدريب كلابك
على التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي وأنت تعرف ربما تعرف
ما يفكرون فيه ، والغرض من
ذلك هو الخوض في عدد من
التمارين بما في ذلك الطاعة الأساسية مثل
بالإضافة إلى كيفية تفاعلهم مع العقبات
عندما نجري التجارب ، فإنه يتيح لنا التخلص
من الكلاب التي لا نعتقد أنها
ستستمتع بالقيام بهذه إحدى الفوائد
ثم الحصول على المزيد من المشاركين لأنه
يمنحك إحصائية  كل القوة ، يمكنك
البدء في متوسط أدمغة الكلاب معًا وا
حصول على إحساس أفضل بما يح
ث ، بدأت أتساءل بجدية شديدة عما إذ
كان بإمكاننا حقًا ال
جابة على هذا السؤال ، هل تحبنا الكلاب بشكل أس
سي فقط من أجل الترابط الاجتماعي وليس حو
الطعام وم
وجدناه  كان ينظر إلى
نظام المكافأة الذي كان لدى جميع الكلاب
تقريبًا استجابات متساوية لكل من الطعام
وكذلك الثناء وحتى بعض الكلاب مثل
الثناء والمزيد من الأشياء التي كنا
نجدها حول دماغ الكلب من نواح كثيرة
تؤكد أنني أعتقد أن ما يعرفه الناس  في
قلوبهم حول كيفية تصرف الكلاب
ولماذا يتصرفون بالطريقة التي أفكر بها في
الكلاب هي من نواح كثيرة
أنهم سفراء لعالم الحيوان ، فهم
لا يختلفون كثيرًا عن العديد من
الثدييات الأخرى الموجودة هناك ، ولذا فأنا أظن
أن  الكثير مما وجدناه هو أن الكلاب
ربما تنطبق على أي
حيوان ثديي تقريبًا
[موسيقى]